hey guys Pete here this will be my part
2 of Queen Cersei first of her name how
long may she reign series if you haven't
seen part one yet I'll put a link right
up at the top side of the screen here
and I would suggest you watch that part
first I had a lot of people leave
comments about the numbers I use for
Circe's potential number of troops and
how they thought they were too high this
might be true as it's pretty hard to say
for sure how many men a fighting age are
still around after the war of the five
kings but one thing to keep in mind is
that the kind of number I was trying to
put together was based on like everyone
I wasn't thinking of just active
soldiers Knights or other types of elite
fighters I meant for the number to be an
estimate of the number of people that's
the ruler of the Seven Kingdoms could
muster in defense of the crown but the
number isn't what the video series is
about it's about how long might Circe
stay on the Iron Throne any estimate of
troops is in the best-case scenario and
that they have to be willing to take up
arms and in many cases sacrifice their
lives for the Queen and part one I laid
out a pretty good idea of what Daenerys
will be bringing with her when she lands
in Westeros her Dothraki and unsullied
are 100% behind her and Dorne and the
Tyrells have every reason in the world
the sea House Lannister fall and
disappear from history the Yara faction
of house Greyjoy also has a good reason
to stay on Dany side since uncle Euron
is currently on a mission to engage in
some kin slaying in regards to her and
Theon so Danny's forces are united for a
common cause and she is the undisputed
leader so let's talk about what option
Cersei has to retain her power and if we
think it's possible for her to do so
there is a chance that she won't be able
to do anything and Daenerys will arrive
and roll right over her but that
scenario doesn't leave much room for
speculation and thus doesn't make for a
very good video
first things first Cersei took the
throne and basically crowned herself by
removing the small Council that served
under her now dead son King Tommen this
seems like it would be a big problem but
if you actually dig into the Baratheon
family line you have to go back about
150 years or so you can end up on Tywin
Lannister's line as part of the
succession Robert's great-great
great-great-grandfather's line splits
off and ends in two places Robert and
Tywin so in reality there is some
credence to the Lannisters taking the
throne legitimately but that's not how
she did it and if you're thinking while
dating in John or Targaryen
don't they have a claim the simple
answer to that is no I mean when a
family topples another and installs
themselves as the royal line you just
don't go back to the other family if a
new one all dies off now people might
support them but technically you know
the crown is still in baratheon hands
and there is no Baratheon heir but again
the proper line of succession isn't the
point of this video either because
matters like that are always somewhat
gray and in the end they're decided by
one thing support technically Gendry
could clay have a claim to the throne
but he isn't a factor because there's no
one left to try to install him or
support him in his bid that's why Danny
can take over she could say that Robert
was a tea server and she has a strong
force behind her that want to see her
succeed there's also a chance that the
small folk would be in favor of this
even though Roberts reign was a time of
peace and prosperity for the most part
things have been hard since the war of
five Kings broke out she was able to win
over the masses if not the Masters in
the East so it isn't that big of a
stretch so what does Cersei have well
she she has the physical throne and what
goes with that in a city with strong
defenses if the small folk didn't love
her before her walk of shame and what
before she blew up the great Sept these
aren't the kinds of actions that would
win them over
remember the sparrows movement was
wildly popular with people who were poor
and those who lost everything during the
war this may not have been as clear in
the show is in the books but people were
signing up in droves all throughout the
countryside when the going gets tough
people look towards faith and Cersei
quite literally destroyed the center of
that faith with her wildfire I think
it's safe to say that her subjects fear
her but they definitely don't love her
as mentioned the number of troops she
might be able to rally his question are
there any other players she might be
able to bring to her cause this is hard
to answer because normally what would
happen in this situation is that she
would marry someone from another
powerful house and get started on
producing an heir this is like the
number one job of any like royal family
and I just don't see Cersei making this
a priority she could do what's been
mentioned in the books that I don't
remember the show ever bringing up but
she could marry Jaime the Targaryen
famous for marrying brother to sister to
preserve their line and even though the
religious powers didn't necessarily
approve they did let it go on in a lot
of cases I don't really see that that's
the way the show is heading but it is
the only scenario where I could see her
trying to produce a new heir who else is
around so
the Tyrells have sided with Daniel I
tried to think of some houses from the
reach who could turn out to be loyalists
we don't really have many examples to
choose from so the one character we've
already met that comes up is randyll
Tarly
there isn't any strong evidence that he
might be a factor other than he was a
loyalist during Robert's rebellion now
that doesn't really mean much because
you know being a loyalist and the
Robert's rebellion was to be on the
Targaryen side so you know your guess is
as good as mine if he might go against
the Tyrells there isn't enough evidence
based on the show randyll Tarly to know
which side he would be on I mean you
know there if he if he goes against the
Tyrells it would be a power play and it
would be you know there would be benefit
but he'd also had to believe that Cersei
was gonna win somehow otherwise
basically his you know they say if she
loses then his family gets wiped off the
map so that's not a real there's no real
strong evidence the other free-agent is
the one that most people think will side
with Cersei Euron Greyjoy this isn't cut
and dry either though
Joran has stated that his goal is to
swing Daini and on the show this is
really all we know about him other than
he killed his his brother and wants to
kill yar and Theon he's a super
interesting character in the books where
there is way more going on with him but
in the show it's almost feels like he's
just there to balance things out I don't
think it's a done deal or anything like
that but I wouldn't be surprised if
you're on Cersei got together to form
team crazy evil even if that does happen
though I don't see your on doing it for
any reason other than to gain power so
once he has it why would he really need
her anymore so I think you're on will
play a part
I think he's setup to be like a really
you know sort of in the way Ramsay
Bolton was he set up to be like the the
arch villain but it's really hard to say
where he's gonna land because they just
haven't given us much to go off of I
haven't talked about the north yet and
my gut feeling is that the north wall
really be involved in the conflict
between Cersei and Danny's this is based
on the fact that jon is the only one who
really understands that the White
Walkers are [ __ ] the real threat to
humanity and I expect him to move
towards the wall to defend Castle black
there's basically no one there and he
knows how important it is to defend it
of course little fingers there and he
may have different ideas he claims his
goal is to sit on the Iron Throne with
Sansa by his
but she didn't exactly sound on board
with the idea
he has sweet Robin and his army and so
he has power behind him but the only
thing we know for sure is that whatever
he does will be in his own self-interest
either way he shouldn't be on sir she's
good side at the moment since he dealt
the deciding blow in the Battle of
bastards against the crown bottom line
is things don't look good for Cersei she
doesn't have the love of her people
which means the factor of them defending
their homes against an animating army
isn't present I'm sure she still has
some wildfire but that only goes so far
she's low on choices for making
alliances and her well defended city is
pretty much negated by the nurses drag I
didn't even mention them in the first
video because I didn't want to seem too
lopsided but yeah they're a big thing I
mean Dragons destroyed City what's truly
crazy is that in spite of all this I
still don't see Cersei losing the throne
right away it's possible just like
anything's possible but I feel like her
story isn't over
besides being against the Dragons she's
pretty safe in King's Landing since she
basically killed everyone who might
oppose her there she has Qyburn the
zombie mountain and Jaime to protect her
locally out of these three I think Jaime
is the wild-card based on the look he
gave her when she was being crowned well
for a lot of reasons really but Cogburn
is no one without her and the mountain
doesn't seem to have the ability to make
the decisions against her will Jaime on
the other hand cares for her and he is
the one who could intervene if she
continues to do crazy [ __ ]
there was a lot made about them how the
Mad King showing up in brans vision was
a foretelling of her using wildfire but
there could also be a connection with
the fact that he killed him rather than
following through with his plan to burn
the city I think there's a pretty good
chance that Cersei will actually burn
the city but maybe that will finally
push Jaime over the edge I think how
long Cersei will reign will be dependent
on what happens with everyone else in
Dan and Dave's first interview where
they gave up some hints on the story in
season 7 they talked about Circe's
journey throughout the season in a way
of finding out who she is without the
love of her children ultimately she
can't win much outside of King's Landing
but I think she will remain in place
there until the end of this upcoming
season it's hard to tell if the formula
for big episodes will be the same with
only 13 of them left total but I think
her death would be in the end of this
season rather than in season 8 in the
books
I feel 100% certain that Jamie will be
the one who kills her so I think there's
a good chance that it'll end that way in
the show too I mentioned in my violent
car video how they left that part out in
the show's version of the prophecy but
either way I think Jamie killing her and
then killing himself is the best
conclusion to their story I think it's a
lot better than her being killed by a
dragon or by Danny who has never met her
if you think about it they could have
just left the word valonqar out because
the average viewer would have no idea
what it meant so even though the
circumstance is different than you know
what drove the Mad King crazy
I mean she's basically the the modern
mad queen she has every reason to be
paranoid because everyone is against her
besides the people that she has right
around her so let me know what you guys
think do you think Daenerys will come
into Westeros and wipe the floor with
Cersei or do you think she will get
sidetracked which would leave time for
Cersei to really explore her dark side
is there anyone who could form an
alliance with that would actually help
her match up against Danny do you think
that there's a chance that anyone other
than Jaime book might kill her do you
think that when she finally gets trapped
and knows she can't win she will burn
King's Landing to the ground with the
remaining wildfire it's a lot to think
about please like the video if you found
it interesting and subscribe to my
channel leave any questions you have in
the comments and let me know if there's
any other videos like this you want to
see thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon